the World Health Organization is calling
coronavirus and info Demick because
there is so much misinformation and
midst out there and hopefully today we
clear those up hi my name is Natasha
Boyan I'm a primary care physician at
one medical and today I'll be answering
the most commonly googled questions
about corona virus is corona virus
airborne no it's not airborne the way
the medical community defines airborne
airborne transmission of a virus means
that viral particles can linger in the
air for hours after it's been exposed
and luckily corona virus is not
transmitted that way we know that corona
virus is spread from person to person
transmission is corona virus worse than
the flu yes we know that the corona
virus for now appears to be more deadly
than the flu the death rate from the flu
is far less than 1% it's usually closer
to 0.1% in fact what we're finding is
the death rate from corona virus is
perhaps around 3.4 percent however that
number it might not be totally accurate
there's other studies that's showing it
might even be 2 percent the reason we
don't know much right now is because
there might be a lot more people
infected than we are testing so the
numbers right now for the death rate
aren't entirely accurate but we do think
that it's more deadlier than the flu
when you break down corona virus
infections by age group that's also when
we see a big difference we're finding
that people who are older than 60 years
old they're more likely to die from The
Cove in 19 disease whereas people who
are under age 40 the death rate from
corona virus appears to be about 0.4% so
less than half of one percent is the
corona virus and pandemic for now the
World Health Organization is not calling
the corona virus a pandemic
a pandemic basically is worldwide spread
of a disease and right now corona virus
is contained to a couple of countries
does corona virus go away about four out
of five people who get the Cova 19
disease will actually end up getting
totally better and for a lot of them
they have very mild symptoms they might
not even know that they have the Cova 19
disease so yes for many people corona
virus can go away kind of coronavirus be
cured right now we don't have any
treatments to cure her own
if you end up getting the kovin 19
disease we do have a lot of things that
can control your symptoms however so if
you have nasal congestion you can try a
nasal steroid it will decrease
inflammation in your respiratory
passageway if you have a cough you can
always try a decongestant and if you
have fevers you can try a fever buster
like an anti-inflammatories such as
ibuprofen or even Tylenol and
coronavirus live on objects the corona
virus is much more common to live on
hard surfaces the way it ends up there
is if someone coughs or sneezes and
droplets get on the hard surface the
virus can be living on the hard surface
anywhere from a couple of hours to a
couple of days
it's less common for the corona virus to
live on soft surfaces like clothing or
carpets but we've seen that before too
that's why it's very important if you
cough or sneeze you do it into a Kleenex
or you do it into the fold of your elbow
why is coronavirus worse than the flu a
really big factor about corona virus is
it's new and we don't know a lot about
it because no humans have had karna
virus in the past we have no immunity to
corona virus whereas at least with the
flu
we've got immunity built up from past
flu seasons and there's a vaccine for
the flu so we've got immunity built up
from the vaccine this is in contrast to
the corona virus which we don't have any
immunity and we don't have a vaccine for
although that's in the works
how is corona virus spread corona virus
is spread from person to person
transmission through droplets what we
mean by that is if you're standing less
than six feet away from somebody and
they cough or sneeze droplets can end up
on you you can inhale those droplets
they can go in through your nose or your
mouth another way it's transmitted is
through hard surfaces so if somebody
coughs or sneezes on a hard surface and
the virus is living there someone else
could touch that virus and then later
touch their face their mouth their nose
and they can get the disease that way as
well there are ways that you can protect
yourself against corona virus number one
is washing your hands frequently washing
your hands takes 20 seconds each make
sure you get underneath those
fingernails and get the back of your
hands as well if you're not able to wash
your hands make sure that you're using
an alcohol-based sanitizer an
alcohol-based sanitizer should be at
least 60 percent alcohol another thing
that you can do is of
avoid touching your face another
important thing to do to prevent getting
coronavirus is wipe down hard surfaces
be sure to wipe down things like
doorknobs tables etc especially if
you're around people who are at risk
what does kernel virus do in essence the
corona virus attaches to cells in our
bodies and it increases our mucus
production it's often impacting our
lower respiratory tract and it can cause
things like coughing and sneezing it can
cause us to get fevers some people with
corona virus also end up getting GI
issues they might get vomiting or feel
nauseated people with really severe
symptoms can also get severe shortness
of breath what are corona virus symptoms
corona virus symptoms are very similar
to the flu and in 80% of cases it's
nearly indistinguishable from the flu
symptoms can actually range from having
nothing at all to having fever and a
cough to having severe shortness of
breath has corona virus peaked we don't
quite know this yet but we don't think
that it's actually peaked in the u.s.
yet because we don't have a lot of
research on corona virus we don't have
good data modeling to tell us how
Colonel virus is going to behave so we
actually don't think it's peaked quite
yet
when will corona virus end we don't
actually know the answer to that public
health officials think that there are
three potential outcomes that could
happen here number one the corona virus
could actually be contained there are
public health interventions and
potentially disappear that's very
similar to what happened to stars in the
past number two we could develop a
vaccine against corona virus and that
could curb a lot of the spread of
disease of Kovan 19 number 3 corona
virus could continue to spread further
and further and end up being a
circulating virus that's just in our
environment I hope that this has
answered a lot of your questions about
corona virus also known as The Cove in
nineteen disease there are a lot of ways
to protect yourself so I don't want
people to worry quite yet number one
make sure that you are frequently
washing your hands washing your hands
effectively means washing for 20 seconds
with soap and water get underneath your
fingernails get the back of your hands
if you're not able to wash your hands
frequently make sure you carry around
hand sanitizer with you the hand
sanitizer you have should be 60% alcohol
based if you have any sort of symptoms
that our respiratory symptoms fever
cough shortness of breath please please
please stay at home avoid going to work
avoid going to public places and avoid
going to crowded places if you have any
sort of respiratory symptoms fever
coughing shortness of breath
sneezing rather than going immediately
to see your primary care provider it's
important to reach out to them virtually
that might be a phone call to your
primary care providers office a message
that you send them or even a video visit
the reason why is oftentimes there's not
a lot that we do to treat a flu or even
the corona virus and it's more important
that you stay safe at home and recover
another thing that we've noticed is a
lot of people have anxiety and fear
about this corona virus it's really
important that all of us are taking care
of our mental health during this time
there's a couple simple steps that we
can all do to be vigilant about our
mental health number one make sure that
you are sleeping a lot of us are not
sleeping or getting adequate amounts of
sleep number two be sure that you're
exercising number three make sure that
you are eating healthy a diet rich with
fruits and vegetables and natural fresh
foods and finally be sure to unplug from
social media and unplug from that
24-hour news cycle if you are feeling a
lot of anxiety during this time please
reach out to your primary care provider
they're able to help you through this
too
[Music]